Is anyone here knows?
She just generally by raise of hands,
how many people were present before she
tell the Chinese journalists in 2004,
the Chinese government distributed
document 11 to Chinese news agents
around the country telling them to not
cover the 15th anniversary of the
Tiananmen Square massacre
was,
had a meeting where a document level of
disgust,
he took those,
type them up and then set them off to a
New York based Pro Democracy Ngo.
She acts with not just one of the
expression,
but it was also an effort to undermine
the propaganda by a,
uh,
by an infested regime.
One of the things that she does cover is
the degree to which the Chinese
government thinks about censorship as
engineers who are thinking about a day.
I'm very politically contentious
moments.
They raised the dam to pay very close
attention to what's going on.
And during liberal periods they let it
go.
Um,
obviously you're an anniversary of the
canvas,
but messenger is a pretty contentious
pack and they're going to be paying very
close attention.
So for instance,
if you send an email with the year 1989
as your username,
if you're going to pay attention to
that,
if you're sending state secrets about a
documentary revealing of propaganda,
a strategy to have political opponent,
United States of America,
they're going to pay attention to that.
They picked up a,
she passed email and they asked Yahoo to
reveal the user information for this
email address from a very tiny second.
We know she has ip address,
we know she tells a email.
This email was sent from a Chicago
address because
God gave it over to the state security
apparatus and she had was condemned to
10 years in prison where he is right.
And there's a real question about how
should,
as United States citizens as residents
of the West,
we react to the United States.
Congress had one answer.
They have a series of hearings and the
inquiries into this during the Sciatica
who was less than forthcoming.
And those hearings culminated in a
northerly anxious tongue lashing by a
representative in the WHO's has
particular experience with oppressive
regimes.
Representative Lantos,
the only surviving member of the
congress.
Um,
who,
uh,
the
conquer
that
game
Herrmann I by the night
jumping
off the matter would not all
what happened,
but I really don't believe that way that
would
lead
me
to
say that we haven't tightened up that
whole lot better than me.
You don't have a
whole lot better.
And like I understand that comment
at the end of the day,
I
have the highlight
in an environment that is very cool
said to the
police,
which pretty much everyone agreed with
except the actual tickets.
Anyway.
We are currently facing a similarly
complex situation,
be enough
as issued a circular which we don't have
access to perhaps because of that have
been translated in English perhaps
because it hasn't made its way out of
the country,
but the circular.
It's bloggers from creating posts which
the government says incite violence or
crime undermine national security,
including inaccurate information or
disclose eight secrets.
And the real question,
I mean there are really two questions.
The first is,
should we ask stakes,
residence,
attempt to change the situation or
attempt to protect the privacy
information of medicines who are based
in are going to break it down to right
now.
That's something everyone is going to be
able to answer on their own in their own
teams and the second half of this
presentation,
the question I'm going to try to explain
the answers to is what we can do.
If we say yes,
we should change.
Yes,
we should go and attempt to use every
power that we have,
every course that we have to protect the
privacy of political dissidents in
China.
So the funnel,
our thoughts on this,
I'm gonna have to defer to professor
Lawrence Lessig who lays out for
metaphors for regulating the content of
flow of human behavior on the Internet
because it's obviously a challenge as to
whether these categories are distinct
all the time.
I mean,
they're definitely learned often as we
learned in law school,
but these are the basic or factors that
I want or that I suggest all of you
think about in determining what your
team's solution is going to lead to.
This problem and what you think
everyone's collective solution should be
for the problem that we're going to
introduce the second half of the class
norms,
mind,
law and code.
Have you guys another 10 seconds just to
look through it.
If there's any questions on this,
feel free to raise them right now.
All right.
I guess we're pretty familiar with this
framework.
So we'll move on to the global network
initiative.
Local network initiative as a sort of
voluntary guidelines which the Internet
companies a specific signatory,
Jerry Yang will get harangued by
representative who they sign onto a
series of principles,
guidelines and a framework for going
forward,
documenting and streamlining the process
by which they interact with the pressing
machines who request private information
of otherwise anonymous for,
uh,
individuals with pseudonyms,
a political dissidents in trunk while
we're political dissidents and across
the world.
Uh,
so we're gonna start with whatever
condition and hopefully by discussing
the details and getting into the
language of this framework,
we can massage out some of the benefits
and tensions of this,
uh,
of this.
Uh,
so we started off with three basic
elements of the global network
initiative,
sort of principles,
which are general aspirations and goals,
the ideals of the signatories,
Google and Yahoo have signed onto this,
a bending implementation guidelines
which are the real meat and potatoes,
the specifics which these companies have
agreed to,
and this framework by the way,
it was set up as a negotiation between
academics,
these companies and human rights groups
mentioned.
And then finally the governance
accountability and learning framework.
A plan for putting this framework into
motion over what is now the next four
years.
So we're going to just start off with a
basic understanding of how these
principles,
the principles are founded upon,
or at least with respect to privacy.
Privacy principles are kind of two basic
claims.
A two basic assertions,
one that privacy is a human right to
privacy is a guarantor of human dignity.
From here,
the guys move on to a series of ships,
some ideals about what,
what,
what these companies are aspiring to be.
A part
starts off with.
Everyone should be free from illegal
arbitrary interference with the right to
privacy and should have the right to the
protection of the law.
Again,
such interference or a test,
right?
Privacy should not be restricted by
governments excepted narrowly defined
circumstances based on getting actually
recognized laws and standards and these
restrictions should be consistent with
international human rights.
Now he's principles are so wide,
so broad in terms of what we can imagine
their applicability to be that they are
inevitably going to be somewhat watered
down when we get to the real specifics.
In fact,
just by highlighting this principles,
a g and I framers were telling us these
are not specific to which we should hold
these Internet companies accountable.
Those specifics are going to come.
Any implementation guidelines still
there is something to point out in terms
of watering down
shaded in gray except the narrowly
defined a circumstance.
The face,
I'm internationally recognized
standards,
so on the one hand the principals
generally close the door on privacy
invasions,
but they always open windows and whether
or not you think this is a good tactic
in terms of what kind of Lsd you all
want to prep,
what kind of approach you want to take
to solve the problem,
and it's up to you.
This is one of the things that I thought
was important to flag and the principal
section will be on implementation
guidelines.
I think it's just important to take a
look at the kind of language which the
implementation guidelines to use.
This is just a section of implementation
guidelines,
just like I like the kind of language of
uses a,
so they're going to receive and evaluate
regular reports for management.
We're going to review and they're going
to participate in training.
All of these words are rather
subjective.
What does review mean?
What does receive mean?
What is participating in ultimately that
is determined by WHO's interpreting it.
These are voluntary guidelines.
Have anything to just specific words
might or might not have an effect.
As we saw in Lauren's less extreme work,
he's will certainly affect norms that a
potentially will affect markets.
Therefore in terms of what he see these
Internet companies doing and me hold
them up to certain norms either by
shaming them or by using our power as
consumers.
That's going to determine how effective
the wording is.
Any implementation guidelines.
So that said,
I've given out a packet to everyone and
I want you to take a look at the privacy
section of the implementation guidelines
now that you have a sense not only of
the principals but also the general
approaches the implementation guidelines
take.
I want you to read through those privacy
guidelines and judge for yourself how
effective they are and whether or not
that would change the approach when you
have a chance to do what they've done in
about 40 minutes.
We'll give you guys about a minute and a
half to do that.
Alright,
so moving on,
we're going to move onto the global
online freedom act,
which is a legislative attempts to use
law to create a different approach that
solves the same problem.
Uh,
so the global online freedom act was
introduced by representative Chris Smith
and it uses a rather more objective
approach to a certain degree.
That might be because of the negative
language that these groups cannot do
that.
On the other hand,
it might be because a judge would be
interpreting,
locate elective or obtain personally
identifiable information,
the
global online freedom that does run
through the State Department,
which only recently has raised a Snafu,
have a bit of an obstacle to the
enforcement of the globe on my freedom
back,
which by the way,
it's only been asked the past in the
house was not passing the Senate.
So there's not long and that's that the
secretary of state has explicitly said
that human rights are going to be
secondary to economic survival during
the recession.
So that is one slight snafu with the,
with gofundme as,
as it's called,
is that it only highlights certain
countries.
Others through Ethiopia I read and
specifically Vietnam.
And that's a problem in America,
which I will go straight,
but they help quite a bit in general
what he does,
and I
know sometimes on this one.
So what do you generally illustrates is
that our own country has been
responsible for major invasions of
privacy.
The NSA most recently has been sued by
the Electronic Frontier Foundation for a
series of more into wiretap and is it
really,
are we really being consistent,
fair,
or is it just something that we want to
do to create a law that only applies to
other countries when our country might
be said to have binding
at the very end.
I'm just going to sum up by just saying
these are the four general forces that
you should think about.
Attorneys not only analyzing these two
solutions but also crafting your colon
and with that we're going to move onto
the guest
is managing director of the Burqa and
sack the cofounder of the information
technology group at Harvard Centers for
International Development in teaching a
course this semester on the technology
and politics,
Internet control,
and he was very involved in the crafting
of the global network initiative.
Andrew Mclaughlin,
which we are trying to prepare early
connect with over skype for to Jack is
joining us from the left coast.
He's the head of the global public
policy at Google,
NC,
your council there,
and he has also taught at Harvard and is
a senior fellow at the Berkman Center.
So I guess we're going to start our
questions with column and the first one
is,
what do you think the optimal use case
is for the Dni and against what
situations is it built to work that
well?
So first,
if I could just,
um,
thank you guys for inviting me here.
I'm sure this will provide a lot more
than my normal environment inside of
asking you to gentle.
I'm not used to being taken apart by the
class.
And second,
important to let you know that I'm
speaking on my own behalf.
Not officially in anywhere.
So we've done part of what we have and
what a lot of us to create.
The sort of trust that we have is
through a great deal of caution with to
speaking on behalf of the people.
These were my experience.
Um,
so kind of before it gets to your
question,
can I kind of just reflect on a few
points in that?
Please do.
And I,
I really wanted to highlight one which I
thought was really interesting,
sort of the focus on aspirational
language and to say that that was very,
that's a very intentional tension that
we introduced.
They're sort of on one hand saying what
can we aspire to and uh,
what's,
what's something that's realistically
implementable and ultimately verifiable.
So I think you're pulling out tension in
the beginning as a suite of documents as
well as see
that particular thing in that that in
particular is important.
So the question is,
what's the ideal case?
What's the ideal use case?
One?
Is the,
there a specific case that he's looking
over?
My,
it's fine.
I guess I should say
this,
I'll start off with a question for you
about,
about human rights in general and your,
these packs.
Well,
if you'd like.
Okay.
So where thing.
We often talk as if there are,
there are,
you know,
big categories as repetitive companies.
Does it,
does it simplify things,
you know,
tend to refer to just google different
anyway,
or
should we,
should we try it aggravated
state?
She and I,
uh,
um,
so,
so it
was both of us decided to do business in
China
town experience and Microsoft find that
itself has been subjected to Chinese
content controls on a,
as a locally hosted service,
uh,
which,
which I don't think it's the,
um,
was that,
uh,
that,
any one of these companies trying to
Tino the government on its own is
basically at a massive disadvantage and
so worth it was a,
we try to aggregate together a lot of
market capital behind a basic set of
principles and the,
I can say in all honesty that this,
this thing was my idea to begin with.
So I can say what I was thinking when
you started this off,
the original idea was that there was one
principal that I thought mattered and
that was the idea that if we could get
the companies to read too insistent,
one basic rule of law process or
censorship,
we'd be able to introduce an element of
accountability and also transparency in
the censorship system.
So you got remember from a kind of
global perspective for a company like
Google anyway,
what Chinese,
what China does is an extreme form of
lots of student.
It's actually isn't an Obama in Europe
this week.
I gave a really interesting answer to a
kind of snarky administrating this
question about American exceptions and
one of the things that he noted,
which is absolutely true,
is that one of the things that is very
exceptional than the United States or in
freedom of speech,
we are in a global context and extreme
outlier when it comes to detection,
meaning speech.
It's fair to say that there's no one to
country which isn't really a metal all
as protected as the US is of dissidence
expression of uncomfortable expression
of last expression and certainly even
Canada or Australia countries which are
in many ways culturally quite similar to
ours,
engage in Ireland,
sponsored censorship in content in a way
that would be recently a
unconstitutional in United States.
So,
um,
so anyways,
so many new roles.
We as a company have gotten into your
commute censorship in Germany and
France,
Brazil and the UK countries,
which are democracies.
And in which competed successive
elective ordinance validated by the
ballot box,
have voted to moser maintain a
censorship machines.
So in Australia,
in classify broadcast content,
they've extended that stream.
Theo in Canada,
they're a national content rules will
use to suppress speech from outside
Canada and prepare the speech inside
Canada.
Germany suppresses a bouncy related
stuff,
extreme violence,
um,
uh,
world,
evocations to go work.
Um,
uh,
you know,
I hate Fox News would probably be
illegal in Germany,
um,
and,
uh,
and so on.
So he,
there are lots of jurisdictions where
you have to do this.
And what's different about training
horses that aids our democracy and the,
um,
the range of speech that is suppressed,
there goes well beyond sort of narrow
defined categories to the arbitrary and
unpredictable a range of subjects that
they,
that they choose to suppress and
experience has shown that in China is,
it's actually a short winded zone.
What is censored is,
is much less today than it was say 10 or
12 years ago,
maybe even five or six years now.
Um,
but there still is a broad range of
things.
The shorthand of it use the,
a,
the,
a three season two teats or um,
uh,
are three t's and Tuesday's Tiananmen
Square massacre.
I wanted dependence to independence.
The first C is with
the last one is criticism with the
communist party's says central
leadership.
So,
um,
those are the things that really got a
internet content blocks.
And uh,
the problem is that there's no rule of
law to.
So if we leave aside the differences in
political systems for a second and say,
you know,
what really distinguishes German
censorship from Chinese censorship,
what answer is that?
German censorship happens in an
accountable framework that's very well
documented.
The law follows the rule sets.
So,
uh,
in Germany there's a body,
a governmental body which produces a
black list.
Are Else,
is subject to oversight from different
parts of the government so that they can
make sure that this apple beyond the
range of things that supposed to be
blocking,
it's got 12 experts from outside the
agency that participative decision
making and presumably could be
whistleblowers and there was something
bad going on.
Um,
and uh,
the black dust itself is not published
for fairly obvious reasons,
um,
a,
the process by which it's implemented,
it's pretty transparent.
So I'm a,
that's one alternative.
The Chinese alternative though is
there's rule of law.
It's basically an individual decision
being accountable.
You're not documentation.
So the,
I cannot make the GI initially,
like I say,
because I first cooked it up was that
you should try to get as much
accumulated market capital in the tech
sector,
media sector and,
uh,
broadly speaking in the information
center and try to get them all to agree
to one second principle,
which is,
that really does follow a censorship
requests on Chinese in services and
actually follow the formal one.
So not for Prom,
not somebody just sending you an
employee to a meeting and yelling at
them to block something.
But if model document that's been signed
off by court,
um,
and again,
this could be usefully transformative at
least in some small way and that
requires some official to attach their
name to an order that follows legal
process at least on paper.
And therefore there's a chain of
accountability built in.
Something gets why you can look at
seafood was that ordered it to be.
One of the things that the fuels,
the range of censorship in China right
now is that,
you know,
you can never really tell it's complete
black box.
The outside world ordered what and for
what purpose?
So that was the original idea.
I'm just one question to ask was better,
um,
it should take.
I think it's largely failed in that
because the only two companies that are
taking on Google or Yahoo and Microsoft,
there are a couple others that I hope to
see getting into the fall by the
stampede and any interest in players
where it's,
this set of rules has not really
happened.
And I think the rule set became a quite,
a bit more prescriptive than what I just
outlined because we also wanted to move
on your recipes others and actually
wanting to push the,
uh,
a formal requirements on participating
companies because they thought they
sorta had to companies over a barrel
because congressional criticism,
pleasure stage.
Um,
and so anyway,
that's something that I broke is going
to be useful,
but it definitely has not lived up to be
the second vibe,
which was the other question you
mentioned google basically the same as
apple,
Microsoft.
Um,
uh,
probably not.
I mean we,
we,
we are much for,
were much more conservative than the
countries that we opened up our
operations in a much more conservative
about the kinds of services that we
deploy and how we deploy it.
So in China,
for example,
we don't locate any personally
identifiable data inside China,
um,
which is critical because even though it
means that our services are quite a bit
slower,
um,
it means that if the Chinese government
never wanted to get personally
identifiable data from us,
they would have to go and file formal
legal process through something called a
mutual legal assistance treaty.
You are,
which means that it goes government to
government from China to the US,
which is Davis,
Ashley Stewart.
Um,
and then the US Justice Department is
involved with the same thing.
We,
we're gauging cooperation.
One of the critical things would be what
the Chinese government is going to use
this data for.
Is it a political dissident or is it a
child?
Pornographer?
Both are possible.
US would obviously,
I think one of the cooperate in an
investigation of the latter than the
former.
Um,
so anyway,
that's,
that's sort of what I know that a
powerpoint that you sent around with,
you were talking about Vietnam,
the announced example country where we
offer Vietnamese language services.
We offer them on adopt 10 domain name,
but we don't actually have any employees
or operations inside China that's
probably different from who was a
Microsoft.
Microsoft sells software,
all the girls.
And so their online division to
probably.
I'm piggybacking off of this physical
presence for us,
we can be a lot more deliberative about
it and they're chosen to be a separate.
There are basically two things that
we're extremely focused in any country
where we're going to put people.
One is access to user data and the
second one is censorship.
And so we study a,
you know,
sort of study the hell out of those two
questions before we make any decisions
about weeds.
We're a data service facilities,
storage facilities,
um,
and uh,
you know,
all different illusions country by
country,
I will say on the censorship score then
what has been extremely challenging is
that because we pulled from the United
States,
there is no country which means us
levels of protection for free speech.
There's a single one anywhere in the
world.
So every country that you go to this got
subject each control or at least
attempts through instruments like the
liability provisions that goes beyond
what would be acceptable know and
kingdom,
for example,
it's libel,
defamation laws,
um,
uh,
and they just act as in order to do a
rules of the liability.
They act as the speech control games.
And that again,
was just a difficult.
So,
you know,
you're looking at a country.
So for me personally,
it's exactly accompanied view,
but a critical distinguishing factor has
been about which countries have
democratic systems which are capable of
correcting errors over time.
So there's that I don't like about
speech restriction laws in India,
let's say a,
but I'm comfortable with Google doing
business in India because when it needs
to state,
which it sometimes does in the form of a
police arresting somebody who posted the
Oregon community that was critical as
somebody for example,
is of course incredibly dismaying that
somebody would be arrested on the basis
of criticism,
on the other hand,
a ideas democratic system for all of
it's a force.
It's a very robust wine in one with the
court system,
which at the top level is,
we've already,
this institution have a tremendous
amount of integrity,
a partial decision making and is likely
to be able to prevent errors as into
mature system.
So I think the profession is probably
unrealistic aiming for something which
is workable,
um,
is,
uh,
is more realistic and try,
just try some kind of balance.
Um,
so one of the things Andrew mentioned
that is that ai is only all has been
going by too much.
The company.
Is that a metric to access your.
So it is a new prevail.
It doesn't have to be arrogant.
Are we to kind of
differences between people or companies
or how would you
respond to that?
First,
I would say that the official launch of
the materials,
which is to say the documents referred
to in the presentation was in October of
2008.
A public launch was in December of 2008.
Uh,
we have ongoing conversations with
probably 20 companies.
We've had a whole host of other kinds of
non-company participants,
which pushes me,
uh,
academics and gos and investment groups,
but most of the social responsible
investors,
I think there's a lot more folks that
we're likely to see.
One of the things that we've been
involved in is in drafting precisely the
governance charter and the terms by
which you can become a member.
So the idea was not that any,
anyone would just join up.
In fact,
we need to establish that they were
committed to this venture and to making
it a success.
One of the things that each of the
companies that have been leading up to
now I've demonstrated through their
longterm commitment and meaningful
engagement and actions and willingness
to address this stuff publicly.
A number of different ways that they
really care about making this work and
that's person not enough,
but a very strong.
There will be accountability.
It's other mechanisms,
but a very strong signal to their
success or their seriousness with which
when they're done with you.
And I had the other thing I would say
that,
so Andrew referred to one sort of
differences among the companies that are
participating now.
Um,
what I would say is that indeed the
point since the beginning has been to
try to get a broader range because now
admittedly we have not succeeded in that
regard.
We did have a series of uh,
other,
other Internet service provider,
a mobile provider and telco types from
Europe primarily involved in the
drafting process,
but the variety of reasons didn't end up
signing on,
uh,
we remain in good contact with them and
never kind of sorta considered we'll see
what happens in long term,
but the plan had been and remains to
ensure diversity and the diversity of
the company so that you don't have folks
using one kind of technology or one sort
of business are operating in one
country.
But rather a mix so you don't end up
with technology specific or region
specific solutions that would not be as
meaningful or as a,
it would be sort of a to two specific.
Of course there's the risk of becoming
too broad,
but that will allow for some sort of
nuance in terms of meditation.
So I'm going for people in.
Your challenge is to get in not just
American companies.
This is key,
right?
If we're going,
we claim to be anything like approaching
global,
a drawing on the ICC bar.
New EHR is not so willing to have,
not just companies with global reach,
but companies that have values based on
non us and indeed non western value
systems.
We need to have a wider range of
companies involved.
So we need to have a telephone,
we need to have other kinds of internet
companies.
We need to have the next Google or the
next company that the social network
would be another group or groups
involved.
So I think the criticism that we have
not scaled,
uh,
we are at scale.
Completely agree with that.
To say that we.
The fact that we haven't scaled this
quickly needs,
it's a failure.
I would say that's an overstatement and
that,
you know,
perhaps if Andrew had been around or
that we would have more company,
so maybe he'll help us get some other
folks to sign on if you will.
So we asked him to go back to window and
I was just an idea,
just an idea.
Even if the had to deal with a lot of
people,
uh,
what was the process like a tear there
to sell it internally to people at
Google?
Um,
what,
what will be most conservatives couldn't
accomplish quality st death as yet
unfortunately.
Treatment,
what would it be concerned is what I'm
drawn out.
Most of the concerns with it.
It just to be too late and too useless
and will be sort of like a pr.
A fig leaf for companies was worse
practices than ours.
I'd say that's probably the primary
thing that we had to.
What's your biggest weakness?
You work too hard.
I just care too much.
But,
you know,
the,
the sales job that we had to,
um,
that we had to,
uh,
you know,
sort of do one on the two guys who
started the goal was to,
um,
you know,
was to persuade them that this wasn't
just sort of like putting people's
weight behind a PR exercise that was
more important to the other participants
that loves to us on the other concern
which was student process was on as a
publicly traded company on the idea of
having sort of outside auditors go
crawling through the company every
couple of years.
Uh,
to judge our compliance with standards
is not one,
it's not one that the lawyers who deal
with no obligations will
tcs to get back.
So we had to cook up a compliance
mechanism which would be,
you know,
just recently trust building but not so
intrusive to trigger a bunch of alarms,
alarm bells in that cereal,
serial informational material,
non public information coming out into
the public in a way,
that
kind of thing.
You're not supposed to do this training
from.
Oh.
So I see some questions from the
audience.
Um,
so I've always been struck by your
observation that if you keep data in the
US,
you can tie governance like the Chinese
government in knots trying to get to it
with letters rogatory and mutual
assistance and enforcement trees and
such.
Because I always seemed to me that if
there were some data that the US
government had reason to think that
Google health does it interest to the
government here,
and Google's answer was it's in China,
don't talk to them.
I think the US government would say,
well go talk to this contempt citation,
you know,
it would be,
you'd just arrest the people who are on
us term and say,
all right,
we're going to keep you in jail until
you talked to the Chinese and get them
to give you the information.
And I always wondered,
isn't the same true on the training side
of things that they,
as long as you've got boots on the
ground engineer's there,
the Chinese can pull your license.
Current restaurant engineer's insert all
sorts of pressure for violating their
domestic law.
If you failed to turn over information.
So how big a difference does it make
that the data is physically on some
other server?
So it's,
it's really good question and either
that better example than China's sale
because actually the facility gets
indicted the head of our Brazil
operation because we were not
surrendering a user,
David,
that was helpful on servers in the US.
One thing difference between the US and
every other country is that because
we're headquartered in the US,
it means that all of the subsidiaries
outside the United States are controlled
by the US.
One of the,
uh,
the converse is not true.
The local subsidiaries elsewhere do not
control the operation in the United
States.
Um,
but even so with what with resilience
did was they were interested in getting
data about people that they claim they
felt child pornographers,
so people that were trading bad images
in working.
So I know that background.
Google runs as a sort of strange 20
percent engineering time project and
social working,
um,
which nobody in the United States a
citizen,
but especially in Brazil in particular,
to a degree that no service,
the United States where they're certain
virtually everybody on the Internet as
we're good accounts and they use it to
keep in touch with each.
I,
I have some theories about why that was
it.
It's awesome.
Brazil actually,
the Berkman center is at the heart
monitor them because three of the people
who were kind of like ground zero users
for the Internet in Brazil were up 49
law.
I'm a add to Berkman center and later
went back.
This is our kaminsky ended up when all
of us and one other guy and they
certainly became a part of the working
group anyways,
so hard work it takes off down there.
But anyways,
so Jonathan,
I believe,
uh,
but uh,
so the working community sort of really
takes off and becomes a big deal in
Brazil and um,
uh,
people were using it for everything that
you used the Internet for.
Right?
So if you're using it to share child
porn images,
they were using it to engage in racist
tribes that were using it to,
uh,
you know,
do all the good things that you know
about,
but they're also easy to do the bat.
So Google's a posture has always been to
never engage others,
sort of control over content,
but rather to be a platform and respond
reactively when users flag things that
are against our terms are against the
law of this stuff will be out there and
it would often be there,
you know,
for law enforcement officials to capture
screenshots and then mom and
complainants.
And so,
uh,
there were um,
you know,
both things which were illegal in the
United States,
like childhood,
you know,
we just did the letter,
um,
uh,
taking place to work and then there were
also fixed that we're not going to be in
that state.
So that would be,
for example,
racism.
So,
uh,
there were no police trying to pursue,
the greeters of racists,
uh,
groups in Brazil and angry.
We meet,
we read an impasse,
impassable.
We told him that they had to go use an a
and m black mechanism to get the data
cooperation with the United States.
They told us so,
you know,
we're gonna make,
we're gonna arrest her people in jail
and so forth.
And indeed they did indict ahead of
personal obligation and extremely
uncomfortable a situation for instance.
So we ended up doing was basically set
up a server inside Brazil and copies of
child porn images and stuff worth onto
that server so that it's actually
physically subject to jurisdiction and
wouldn't be violating US law by channel
data
outside of the bounds of legal process.
Um,
and uh,
that's standard office suite works.
But,
um,
and we also,
you know,
if the problem is now
the problems that the United States law
speced specifies that that will be
discovered.
A child born in HR systems somewhere.
He notified the FBI,
which gives you and that you're sharing
that eventually a organization called
the National Center for missing
exploited children,
which is a great organization to an
executive and financially and they do
excellent sort of forensic work out on
the Internet to try to track people down
and it couldn't trust,
but they'll also is very.
That is the only organization that we
are legally allowed to treat.
These images have overtaken.
And so,
uh,
you know,
we had to sort of go through a process
of getting a,
getting a kind of an okay for us to have
these images are shared.
We the resilient law enforcement and
impossible.
This is just a silly law.
It just needs to be fixed because
there's no point in saying that to us.
These are forbidden from sharing a legal
activity elsewhere if law enforcement
elsewhere.
Um,
but,
uh,
it was a question that you asked is
what's the socket just arresting and
invoice?
The answer's nothing.
I mean,
they,
they did do that.
The problem is that,
you know,
you start to look like a hostel and
unreasonable environment for investments
and for Internet companies to operate.
One advantage that we have is that even
police chiefs and government officials
in districts and countries like and
using,
um,
and find that it's useful so they,
they're often not particularly
interested in going the nuclear rooms
and pulling her licenses,
kicking us out of the country and
resting air holes.
So let's,
uh,
let's change topics a little bit and so,
um,
say when you mentioned the foundation
Congress last term was paying a bill
called Blah Blah Blah.
And that was,
that took a different coach than,
uh,
than,
than the Gi.
But for all,
for this question,
just all you know is that you're not
anymore and I will never been.
I wouldn't say so.
Let's say the Congress instead,
he says you'll have some kind of APP.
It says American companies doing
business abroad.
He's accurate.
He sent me to a sign up for it.
What happened is that,
is that an APP?
Let's see.
It will be up to us to make it into
that.
But I think,
you know,
as of right now,
it would be a little difficult to go
from having three companies and a total
of 20 participants
invest with the scale required level
adjustment on one hand,
upside down,
some of our notions with respect to
governance and cool and underworlds
firms,
they agree to participate.
So I think that's an adjustment that you
make in terms of the,
um,
but that's,
that's more process oriented.
I think in terms of the,
um,
the guidelines said the patient better
and so forth.
It would absolutely skill.
I mean,
this is giving me maybe for all his
criticism
as to the rule of law,
of course,
that's a significant part of the GNA and
to introduce process is where there has
been no process which has been a major
heading,
a profoundly negative impact on you.
Um,
so in many respects this would be a
great game,
right?
To have everyone participating in this,
uh,
a snap of the other things you do is,
is that as we have a greater number of
participants in more diverse markets
around the world,
it gives us the opportunity to have a
greater transparency so that instead of
just asking Google to release this block
list or it's sort of statistics which
it's been,
it may be elected to do for,
it could in fact highlights behavior in
front of a certain document,
either compliance or lack of compliance
to aggregate collectively the statistics
of the number of different,
uh,
the number of different companies to get
the show to both policymakers,
users,
activists,
and others.
In fact,
what's happening so,
so move away from censorship.
Censorship is a problem or a privacy,
your privacy,
your private information.
It's not really safe towards saying this
is how unsafe it is or this is how big a
problem with this is the trend.
In fact,
we're seeing greater and greater amounts
of censorship or we're not really.
Maybe it's this.
Andrew says it's actually other problem
is that is finishing.
So that one of the,
one of the sort of medium term goals
with Gsi,
which is the rule of law,
is to generate this kind of data so that
we can actually have empirical
information about what's happening and
that then a citizens users,
uh,
atmosphere organizations,
companies and policy makers can make
choices based on that information.
So make a note about that.
So as censorship is not diminishing or
why should,
I think we're experiencing right now,
a massive surge all fly expansion in
censorship.
It's not interestingly,
it's not happening in China.
It's happening again in a vast swath of
countries in western Europe,
on Asia,
Southeast Asia,
South Asia and so forth.
I'm sure you had.
Your country is now attempting to impose
restrictions on the Internet in the name
of copyright,
in the name of child protection,
in any combat and indigo activity and in
the case of many telcos in the name of
a differentiating services and,
and in a fast and slow lanes for
different kinds of content.
Um,
so from,
from my perspective,
actually,
this is a,
a gathering storm seating.
And,
um,
I think for the US government,
this is something that needs to be taken
very serious.
I'm leaving aside the exportability of
American values like freedom of
expression in the old tradition of John
Mark and John Stuart Mill Constitution.
Uh,
we have an economic interest in that
information center which generates a lot
of cash and jobs to be kind of embracing
about it is this,
this is the single biggest trade
barriers we faced.
Um,
so I actually think that the perspective
of either legislation or executive
action for both,
there's a pretty wide.
So it's worth considering and see if the
United States can use.
It's a whatever remains our economic
power worldwide.
All in the service of freedom of
expression offer individuals worldwide
cause it's in the interest of our movie
industry or a TV or newspaper industry's
Internet companies.
And so we've all got an interest in
being able to move information without a
enduring.
The,
um,
uh,
many complex and expensive censorship
regime center are,
many of them are very well intentioned
that they're not going to traditional
where,
uh,
you know,
adults autonomy is not a,
it's not the prevailing value rather
than freshman social values,
um,
is,
uh,
so I actually just there another big fan
of the name which would be this building
highlighted,
for example,
on an basis barely make it illegal for
us to deliver it in an email message to
China because of the way it's written.
But,
you know,
even leaving that aside,
I think there probably are things to be
get you to try to raise the bar,
a little wall in center,
our trading partners,
uh,
to create a,
an environment in which our companies
are edited,
uh,
regardless of,
of,
of censorship restrictions
against the background of that last
comment,
which seems strong.
It's not at all clear to me why you
think that reliance on the foundational
principle of the rule of law is going to
help.
It would seem just discussed the
alternatives scenario for moment still
there because you just disappeared from
the screen now.
There we are.
Yeah,
I'm here.
I can hear you.
Okay.
So the alternative scenarios,
one image you've combined the increased
willingness of governments to,
um,
to engage in overt forms of censorship
with the trend exemplified most recently
by the Goldsmith book acknowledging the
technical feasibility of country
specific management in such an
environment.
It would seem that the rule of law,
uh,
to the extended connotes open processes
of making an independent judiciaries is
not going to do anything to retard the
imposition of controls on speech.
It just have legislatures in Saudi
Arabia is saying actually we think
sexualities and bad idea and the judges
appropriately commissioned to execute
the law say,
and we think sexuality is a bad idea and
we're going to clamp down on it.
So why is there any advantage to
employing the mechanisms of the rule of
law to resist the coming storm?
It
so is in
a structural answer of rule of law and
accountability and transparency answers
you struck with Scott,
unaccountable,
nontransparent,
secretive,
the structural answer that answered
substances,
just social consensus.
As a group censorship,
that means you still also have to add
the substantive arguments and build a
substantive case why he should not
attempt to the memory of Kemal Ataturk
or protect community shake you.
I think that it's an answered you didn't
problem.
And so I can engage in,
in a,
in a series of arguments possibly to
economic and diplomatic.
It's a to do subsequent.
Can you vote for questions here?
So now you've got a little bit of
background on the issues in a democratic
cross international borders and a that
we're going to make you do it.
So welcome everyone to the first
international conference on Democratic
Free Speech Online.
It is a build on facts because we ended
up last week that,
um,
there is a recent case in which a,
a,
a Vietnamese missive to Internet service
within Vietnam telling them which sites
are blocked was given out to various
products.
We didn't have a staff member of one of
the Vietnamese Internet service
providers blog about the list of blocked
sites on his,
um,
his pro-democracy blog published by
Yahoo,
which is the most popular blogging
service in Vietnam today.
That was picked up by Rebecca Mackinnon
global voices,
which is a popular,
a Franchisor of individual for an
auction,
bloggers around the world,
and that wasn't picked up by the New
York Times,
New York Times story upset that the
enemy is government.
Government in turn has come together to
ask them to give up the names of the
people who were blogging this
information.
Now,
uh,
it turns out this is the backdrop for a
group of international actors getting
together and saying,
we see this problem far too often.
We'd really like to come up with a
solution that's going to allow all of us
to be satisfied with procedures that we
have for dealing with these problems.
So we are going that each of you,
your six groups,
and I should name the six groups right
now,
the government of Vietnam here,
we have a group of Vietnamese Burnham
auction bloggers.
You can just assume we're all wearing
masks.
So the government of Vietnam doesn't
spot on and take them home right now.
Um,
the United States Congress,
a reputable August dissertation,
um,
the Board of
international and convincing just
because they like look up the shoulders
with their friends again,
China.
So,
uh,
right now what we'd like you to get to
do is take five minutes,
discuss what it is that you'd like to
see as your actor in and sort of an
international system for dealing with
these kinds of problems as they arise.
Each group should elect someone to act
as a communications director.
That person should,
a laptop,
then we're going to engage in two rounds
of sending people to other people's
vacation is director or from various
parties,
negotiate over the agreement that every
part of the commitment.
So for example,
we would take amnesty,
Amnesty were to relax,
you know,
room to be director,
and then we send them over to various
other groups can negotiate with them
over terms and everyone can agree with
to come back to their communications
director and to write it into the final
document that Amnesty International,
uh,
we're going to have a second round of
meetings within the group.
You can discuss what you heard from
anyone else.
And a second round of negotiations and
then each group is going to present it
solution and explained to us first why
it thinks it's a good solution for it's
so valuable.
Why Amnesty International in particular
sport the EMC solution,
and then liked good solutions of the gen
and it's sort of a desirable overall
answer.
So with that in mind,
I'm going to give you five minutes
starting now.
She can sit with your groups,
discuss exactly what you're negotiating
strategy conveyed and I'll let him know.
So the idea here is that not only that
but also to win the vote.
Which solution is the best solution.
So when you got here negotiating for
your needs,
you're also negotiating.
Our first presentation is going to be,
you
guys want to spend two minutes,
why you for you?
Apparently I'm not so much into free
speech,
which is probably a,
but we're essentially DMTA style.
Notice the take down because we
recognize that
the Vietnamese government is never going
to allow us to just post whatever we
want online.
So it exchange for this Cape Town.
We were asking for the right to remain
anonymous and that will also get
immunity from criminal penalties.
And so why we thought this matter
interest are interesting word that one
you have to post.
Um,
and we also though,
we don't want to make Vietnam too bad
because we want economic growth.
So that's what I mean.
The second group that we got was a Yahoo
International.
We'd like to present yet
Yahoo,
the greatest collaboration with the
Vietnamese and the Chinese government
game,
the following solution,
finding arbitration underneath the
existing,
the World Trade Organization Rishi,
such that if the government has a
problem,
if the Vietnamese bloggers have a
they can bring it to the attention of
his international body.
The governments will have signed onto
the GSI and principle and we can have a
binding arbitration's that uses the
economic,
carrot and stick of the WTO arbitration
per blog post.
Important general class action
arbitration.
The
details are that each country wouldn't
have their own boss.
That basically kind of caught up by
their interpretation of Gina.
Both Vietnam and China agreed in
principle to kind of aspire towards Dni
principles in,
in respecting privacy,
so in each individual case there will be
processes and procedures and laws and
the Chinese in China and Vietnam which
be independent and respect their
sovereignty now in extreme cases to the
extent that either party it the
government or the blogger has a a major
kind of dispute.
There would then be in a process by
which the either party could appeal
these extreme cases to the WTO in that
arbitration would inviting under the WTO
of which both is there a two inch,
both Vietnam and China already kind of
our members,
the exchange of information.
Really a trade issue here
and that's that.
So the idea is that not that not only
not only respects the sovereignty of
both of China and Vietnam,
which we think are paramount,
but it also kind of creates an
international,
a set of principles that other countries
can aspire to,
which is,
which is what the Gi represents.
Hopefully this will keep other countries
to kind of start using guidelines,
guiding principles in addition to the
fact that it kind of respects the
privacy of the bloggers and the interest
of groups like Amnesty International and
finally,
truly I think we think expands the
global economic high
nine zero seven transactions.
That's what we're about.
We're
with launch with the WTO,
not for being a disciplined and being
arrested for that,
but for having his information turnovers
in future cases.
There would be a procedure in place for
dealing with situations like this.
You try to because that's extremely.
Yes.
Alright,
gentlemen,
the next up,
the Chinese have a presentation or
proposal.
I'm not sure I actually agree with you,
was pretty sort of the WTO.
Um,
we don't really.
Our main proposal is that we think that
countries should agree to adopt the
United Nations on Peachtree Hispanic
program being dropped to about
[inaudible] 70.
Um,
beyond that,
I think our position is that we're not
going to have a sign on the agreement
here no matter what.
Basically has it all,
um,
as,
as an interstate matters from the wheel
bolts,
it's commitments to letting countries do
what they want within their own borders
and not having other countries dictate
to 100 dictate to another country what
they should be doing.
So
is there anything here,
but we won't sign on to anything
that we don't with that is imposing on
our,
our society,
someone else's.
So now no international arbitration is
going to satisfy if it's not binding,
said Cheryl,
we might sign onto that.
Fair enough or it could be like the US
and even if it is binding and we started
going through and just ignore what it
says
that,
but that sounds reasonable.
The United Nations a q,
six,
17 group life.
Yeah.
That's
alright.
Next up we'd like to hear from the
United States Congress.
So we realized that,
um,
there are a lot of definitions of state
sovereignty play here,
which is why,
um,
that,
uh,
we set up some sort of ex ante
procedure,
uh,
in order to determine what sorts of
information requests are really
justified by telling me which ones
aren't.
Uh,
so we propose a recording either a
committee or,
or,
um,
an official within the US State
Department who would review requests,
formal
requests,
uh,
from,
the relevant government,
um,
uh,
to determine whether there exists a
compelling need for information such as
a,
uh,
a realistic connection to some sort of
terrorist activity.
Uh,
and if such a need exists to then
authorize the ISP,
our ISP is in question to a handover,
the relevant information to,
uh,
the request and government,
the ISP is,
would not be subject to penalties,
uh,
in this country unless they hand over
information that has not already been
authorized by the government.
Otherwise,
the US or the US government.
all negotiation,
uh,
all interaction interactions take place
on a state to state level,
but all the information that would go,
all the permission,
we'll go through this committee.
So any information that was turned over
to governments that didn't go through
this committee would not be authorized
by Congress
government.
Uh,
yes,
with the symmetric interpretation now
he had put in our original legislation
that we got some feedback,
um,
many of these companies in a very
difficult position where they would
either be forced to define local laws
are approved by our laws and we thought
it would be in the interest of bloggers
and democratic decisions around the
world to have the tool of the internet
at their disposal instead having yahoo
just leave the country for fear of
reprisal from whatever dictatorship.
So we've got that by keeping this in the
diplomatic sphere and by not trying to
harness the economic incentives that
Isp,
we would actually be doing a greater
service to people who wanted to use the
internet.
The American government wanted to get
information that will poses overseas
against the wishes.
Say they're with us,
recede on applying pressure of the sort
that Andrew was talking about.
Contempt of court for those assets are
people we can get our hands on.
They have a process like this place
that's classified
the US Congress now Amnesty
International.
So
our proposal is based on this principle
that when it gets into trouble,
a large number of parties who support
the rights,
including a state and non state actors,
should have taken interest in exercising
all our necessary to defend that
blogger.
So that starts with us setting up a
network of pro bono lawyers in every
country who works specifically with
local laws concerning speech and also
lobbying governments to strengthen some
sort of private right of action,
which is worthless when you're a blogger
who's secretly arrested,
um,
but does do a little something towards
establishing international norms.
We visualize the process is working on
those Vietnam complaints and Yahoo
alerts the blogger and get the water a
chance to correct false information or
pull the post.
And I think we saw some agreements on
the idea of pulling the post and Yahoo
alert sauce and we activate our network
of pro bono lawyers so that this
anonymous blogger has some legal
representation in their home state.
Um,
and then we'd have a review board
possibly based in the WTO that might
include a mechanism for anonymous
mediation between the Vietnamese
government and the blogger who's in
trouble,
although we know that there's a risk of
espionage here in anonymous mediation.
Um,
the board could later can include the
TNI countries and maybe if,
if things are really not going include
other interests in nations,
hopefully United States.
So the idea is that we can really just
make this issue explode on the
international level,
make an international incident out of
one nation,
attempts to get to a single blogger.
I'm,
we'd also like to see an extension to
the GSI that would mandate that all
these companies participating in
protecting speech rights online could
work together and collectively bargain
with say,
the Vietnamese government.
So the nuclear option would look a
little something like this.
Vietnam says turnover.
Yahoo,
who says no negotiations totally fail.
Things are going very badly.
Microsoft,
Google and Yahoo unilaterally pull all
surfaces out of Vietnam,
which isn't awful for Vietnam in terms
of being competitive in a global market.
Um,
I think that's what a
lot of state right now,
so.
Okay.
And then our final group is Vietnam.
Sure.
So I'll start.
Um,
we,
we talked to a good number of parties
and that we feel very strongly that
yahoo was obliged to turnover a blogger
on the,
a state secret with a.
We do not believe that we move into post
remedies.
The problem that we do with the blogger,
no more than we gave.
Julia said,
Ethel Rosenberg,
oopsies.
I'm making that up,
that this is a
no,
no more than anyone would have done.
This is a very serious matter.
This is a,
this is something that requires that
judicial system of Vietnam going.
The fact that we believe that we offered
you processed by our laws,
that we have all of the procedures,
that we are willing to comply with the
best practices of the GSI and for future
forward looking proposals including
modifying the underlying infrastructure
of the internet or have proven to WTO.
We were willing to take these proposals
very seriously.
We just joined the WTO two years ago
that we are country with very low
internet presence.
And so we are not willing at this time
to commit ourselves to a abrogating any
jurisdiction,
um,
and we are in fact willing to tell the
other if it's unwilling to follow the
laws no differently than if they decided
not to follow the minimum wage laws.
We are comfortable proceeding against
the company for violating our last,
um,
and that we,
we believe that there was some agreement
that so long as the country follows the
piece of law certainly does that she and
I have principals are respected and that
this is something that I think a lot of
parties agree to.
A little bit of feedback on.
Some of the ideas we've gone here and
then we're going to take a boat.
Um,
so,
uh,
first the DVCA style notes and take
a.
So I thought,
let me just start.
Okay,
go and think those are very creative
ideas and I will certainly take them
back towards you.
And I
know
I'm going to take a little while to
process that.
The DNC was definitely interesting.
I liked how you kinda came up with the
tradeoffs.
You just sort of that benefit.
I'm not sure that the Vietnamese
government is necessarily going to be
really thrilled with that and it's.
I mean,
I certainly love the idea of preserving
anonymity,
but from what we've heard about the
Vietnamese government,
they may not necessarily.
They may have other ways of knowing who
you are,
so I'm not sure that you're really going
to preserve your referring to key
loggers and other trojans and this
precise.
I'm trying to remember what the
Vietnamese isp situations,
but my recollection is that there's,
there's a pretty close tie to the
government in a lot of instances.
I'm not sure how they're gonna feel
about it,
but certainly it seems like a good start
to see,
well if there is a problem and someone
does say,
Hey,
I want to blow the whistle on this does
scale unlike some of these other
solutions which I think are going to
have a real challenge with scaling.
Um,
whether there's potential for abuse in
the DSCA style thing.
And certainly people have argued that
there have been abuses in the US of a,
on that front end therapy.
Similarly in these context.
So what about international arbitration?
When Debbie came back,
there were some up.
The trade issue is interesting and this
is certainly something that the
companies have pursued.
I don't know that anyone has really felt
that adding it into WTO,
maybe tim mover and paper that was
advocated for epic adding into WTO,
but my suspicion is the scaling issue is
one problem.
How does it work?
How does it work in practice when you
have a pretty substantial number of
actual replaces a possible,
when you have a legitimate law
enforcement,
how do you determine the difference
between those two things?
What does it mean?
I think you guys also had government
signing on the GSI.
I have no clue without looking in
practice if a lot of it's about
responsible company behavior piece of
it's interactions with governments
rather than responsible government
behavior,
which it shouldn't be falling in some of
the US anyway,
that somebody or perhaps that universal
declaration,
declaration of human rights to.
It's mostly,
I assume that I have to be quite frank.
Um,
and uh,
I think the value of women within Dni,
there is a venue for complaint.
There is a third party complaint
mechanism that we're working on right
now,
so I had a that needs to be some space,
but I'm not convinced that the WTO,
which hasn't arguably been super kind to
some countries,
wouldn't really do the best place.
I'm sure they do.
I
is that Chinese book before the
International Telecommunications Union
to retrofit the Internet so that all
communications are traceable.
It's proceeding for studying from now
until 2012 for the Chinese herbalist.
Very hard and ACB and finger in this
class as well.
I mean,
so I guess to the rest of new attorneys
may have this already involved in mind,
but I think what you would see as sort
of always seen with a lot of other
technologies that there would be scope
creep and uh,
what you might,
when you start out with your filtering
or sensory activity,
you begin to filter out or filter or
search for child porn only.
And then child porn moves into kind of
other objectional speech.
Like,
I don't know,
the political opposition or different
ideas of religion.
So forth.
And I think you could see very likely a
scope creep with this.
I also wonder,
I mean,
so that's the scary side.
The other side is I tend to be a juvie
excited the fold that any technology
fixed will remedy anything that there's
always going to be a technology fix.
Um,
and uh,
perhaps that identify you by your,
you're a very noble aims,
but perhaps it's enough if you can make
people think that they can be traced
that sufficient.
Congress is committee that looks out for
every single piece of intervention.
So that to me sounded sounded very
boastful.
Like if my recollection of the bill is
accurate in
that same,
he seems like it would be pretty
difficult to practice.
My recollection is that piece and the
international legal processes like this,
another defer to the lawyers in the room
and all of which
you and me is that you're looking at a
few years currently to get many of these
sorts of questions resolved.
So going from a few years to being able
to resolve the volume of questions,
not just from Vietnam but from all the
other countries around the world would
seem like the presenting the real
challenge and I think Jonathan's
questions as to what's the flip side of
this is real important that we could end
up in a similar situation
we have to eat on go
what about a industry international
network of pro bono lawyers in secret
ucl as well.
So there were definitely some fun
elements of,
and Mystique
is all about fun.
Yeah.
Criticism and it didn't seem there was a
lot of stick
which we would expect,
but I liked it.
I thought the Yahoo alerting blogs.
Interesting.
I mean,
I think it depends on the jurisdiction,
but most places I think it's generally
illegal and you guys got to get it
corrected.
If I'm wrong to alert someone that law
enforcement has requested their,
uh,
information,
unless it's for a civil procedure in
which some cases.
So my suspicion is that that's probably
depending on whose laws to follow that
could present some problems for them.
Um,
but,
uh,
I,
I like that as a way of saying is there
some way that we can work and try to
remedy this situation internally?
The lobbying government doesn't
necessarily strike me as something
that's gonna go too far since that's
already happening right now,
but perhaps it might institute some
change,
um,
ended up Bono provolone or whereas is
interesting.
I think it would be pretty neat if you
could get lawyers to sign on to do that.
But of course what we've seen in a good
number of countries is reprisals against
those lawyers.
And this is often a lot of settings
which we want our jurisdiction.
I'm sure you do.
But I also do think,
I don't think you want them to their
option.
I don't think you want.
I think that within your government
there are a lot of different factions
and some,
maybe I'm more dug in on this sort of
control and others in fact may be open
to a more progressive approach and might
find it.
And I suspect that this is always the
case.
We'd like to talk about governance is
monolithic,
but that in fact there's more variety or
more diversity of views in the
government that if the these companies
were to lose or there were to be or to
leave or if there were to be a large
international dispute that it would cost
you some and certainly your relationship
with the US.
Well,
I supposed to.
China is significant in terms of the
economic terms and I don't think while
you don't necessarily want to bend over
backwards to please the Congress,
um,
you at the same time,
we're probably not eager to,
um,
to cause some major international
so they wouldn't take a vote.
Executive catching over my two minutes
already.
I'm thinking perhaps take a boat over
the class.
Any of your feedback on hold you here
any longer than we actually happen.
So thank you very much for
participating.
Thank you.